- I'm Julian.
I'm a Developer Advocate at AWS,
working with the Serverless team.
And I love helping developers turbocharge
how they build applications
using all the cool things Lambda can do.
Rajesh.
- Yeah, hello, everyone.
I'm Rajesh Pandey, Principal
Engineer with AWS Lambda.
I've been with Lambda for six years now,
and in that time I have
watched Lambda grow
from thousands of customers
to like millions of customers,
and it's been an
incredible journey for me,
and I'm looking forward to
sharing some of those fun stories
with you all today.
- Cool, excellent.
Can't wait.
- Yeah.
- So today we're gonna talk,
continue, actually, a
series of different Lambda
under the Hoods over previous re:Invents
to help you understand
Lambda a little bit more.
And I'm gonna go over
some Lambda fundamentals,
how various invokes work
and spend some more time on
our polling capabilities.
And then Rajesh is gonna come back in
and head proper down the rabbit hole
and do some interesting
lessons on how we built Lambda,
how we made the choices we did,
and even more information on the pollers.
Now, to be honest with you,
a part of the magic of Lambda
is a lot of what we're gonna cover today.
You don't actually need to know.
We just handle it all for you.
It's a super amazing service,
and we love explaining how it works
so it doesn't seem so mysterious,
just maybe magical in how it
works at such great scale.
So let's start with a trivia.
Who wants to know probably
the biggest secret
of the serverless?
Anyone?
Well, actually, there are quite
a lot of servers underneath,
sorry to tell you, hundreds
of thousands, in fact.
And you as a consumer never see them.
Because we, AWS,
manage all of this underlying
infrastructure for you,
allowing you to focus on
your business scenarios.
And with Lambda,
we like to think of that
you just bring your egg,
your code, the life of your business.
And we've built an
incredibly resilient nest
at scale to look after your egg.
Because it means
you don't have to build a
whole bunch of things yourself.
Things like auto-scaling
logic, AZ failover,
you know, retry logic, connection pooling,
back pressure,
lease management, all these
different kind of things,
we take that on so you don't have to.
And this obviously runs at massive scale.
More than 15 trillion invokes each month,
with a whopping 1.7 trillion invokes
just on Prime Day alone.
99.99% availability and
resilience built into the service
so you don't have to pay extra for it.
And so let's do a recap of
some Lambda fundamentals.
One of the major technology
foundations of Lambda
is the open-source Firecracker,
but now we're actually
expanding the foundation
to include good old EC2.
Lambda Managed Instances,
announced on Sunday,
gives you Lambda's operational simplicity
with EC2's range of instances.
You can choose to use
Graviton or CPU or memory
or network-optimized instances
for your Lambda functions.
And you don't have to manage
any of these instances for you.
You also get up to 12% savings,
12 times savings for AtScale workloads,
and multi-concurrency,
and EC2 pricing incentives,
all part of the package.
There's also a session, CNS382,
which you can find out more about it.
With normal Lambda, so-called on-demand,
everything runs in the Lambda service VPC.
And invokes come in from clients
and ultimately run on EC2
worker hosts owned by Lambda
in the Lambda service VPC.
With Lambda Managed Instances,
the control plane stays
in the Lambda account,
but we provision and manage
EC2 instances in your account
in your VPC and then
route function invokes
to containers running on them.
So Lambda on-demand with Firecracker
and Lambda Managed Instances,
two different compute models,
but the rest of the architecture
basically stays the same.
Lambda's got three invoke types.
Synchronous, when the
caller calls either directly
or via API gateway
and this sends the request
to the Lambda service,
does its processing, waits for a response
before returning it to the client.
When you do an asynchronous request,
either via client call
or maybe something like
an S3 change notification
or an EventBridge rule
matching, sending an event,
you don't wait for a response
from the function code.
You hand the event off to Lambda
and Lambda just handles the rest,
places the event in an internal queue
and the returns are successful.
The response to the call is
saying, "I got your event,"
and then a separate process
goes and processes it.
And event source mapping
is a Lambda resource
that reads items from a
queue like Kinesis, Dynamo
or from a, sorry, from a
stream like Kinesis and Dynamo
or from a queue like SQS
and a producer application
would've put messages onto this.
And then Lambda-managers the pollers,
which we're gonna cover today.
So read the messages
and then send them onto
your invoke for processing.
The Lambda API is the Frontend
where all requests to
the Lambda service land.
And it is multi-AZ load balancer resolving
to Lambda dot whatever region
name dot amazonaws.com.
And then this routes the invoke
request to the data plane
and then ultimately lands
up on a worker host,
yours or ours.
That's it.
That's the journey of events in Lambda.
Rajesh, I think we're done.
Okay. There's obviously a little bit more
which we can talk to you about today.
So we should continue.
The Frontend load balancer distinguishes
control plane request from invoke requests
and these can be function configuration
or resource management from the console,
CLI tools or an SDK.
The data plane requests the route,
then route to the separate
data plane one for Sync Invokes
and one for Async Invokes.
And the Sync Invoke service
is actually technically called
the Frontend Invoke Service
and Async the Event
Invoke Frontend Service.
But you know, naming things
gets a little bit confusing,
so we're just gonna
stick with sync and async
to keep things a little simpler.
And this is actually a deliberate choice
to separate the data planes,
which was built into the
system a few years ago
when basically we had a huge async spike
which overwhelmed the sync service.
And so now we can protect the sync service
from async floods.
The data planes also
fleet of stateless hosts.
Lambda again is an AZ
service, a multi-AZ service,
so you don't have to worry
about load balancing
your functions across multiple AZs.
Lambda handles it for you.
For performance and stability,
the data plane needs to get
information about functions
from the function versions Dynamo table,
which we cache both on the hosts
and also in an L2 AZ cache.
'Cause we wanna make
invokes as fast as possible,
so we wanna avoid having to look up things
on every single invoke and it
also helps with availability
this way of doing it too.
So let's now look at the
synchronous path in more detail.
So the ALB distributes the invoke request
to a fleet of hosts as part
of the sync invoke service.
I'm simplifying the diagram here
as it's gonna get a little crazy,
but Lambda is built to everything
runs across multiple AZs.
So the sync invoke service first performs
some authentication and some
authorization of the request
and this is gonna ensure
that Lambda is secure,
as only authorized callers
are gonna be able to even get
through Lambda's front door.
The service then is
gonna load the metadata
with their request.
The Frontend also calls what's
called a counting service.
This is gonna check
whether any quota limits
may need to be enforced
based on the account
or reserve concurrency.
The counting service is also
optimized for high throughput,
needs to be under one and
a half millisecond latency
as it's called on each invoke.
And as it's critical to the invoke path,
it's also highly available
across multiple AZs
and super fast.
The Frontend then talks to what is called
the assignment service
and also there's a control plane service,
another component which
manages then the coordination
and manages background tasks.
It handles those control plane things
like creating functions
and then also manages the lifecycle
of assignment service nodes.
Back to the assignment service.
So this is gonna then coordinate
the placement service.
And so for the first invoke of a function
and new execution environment needs
to be started on a worker host.
A placement service
is then gonna create an
execution environment
on a worker with a time-based lease.
It's also gonna monitor worker health
and make the call winter
mark a worker as unhealthy.
So once execution environment
is then up and running,
you can see the in it path.
The assignment service is
then gonna give your supplied
I am role and also environment
variables with the privilege,
the I am roles with the
privileges you define,
and then also the environment variables
and give it to the worker.
The execution environment
is then gonna start
the language runtime,
you know whatever it is, no Java, python,
and then download the function code
or run the container image
and then the function in it process runs.
Then the sync invoke
service runs the invoke
and your function runs
and sends the results back to the caller.
To minimize latency,
it's called directly to an
invoke proxy on the worker hosts.
And then when subsequent requests come in,
well the Frontend's gonna check,
talk to the assignment service,
which says yes, we have already
got a execution environment
all up and running,
and he's gonna route the
invoke payload directly
to that accused execution environment
and again, run the handler.
When the lease of the
execution environment is up
or there's some kind of error,
the assignment service is
able to gradually drain
the connections, spin down
the execution environment,
stopping future invokes.
So let's take a little
bit of a deeper look
at some of the Lambda workers.
So a worker host is just a
standard bare metal EC2 instance
in which we place execution environments.
Now to be efficient
and get invokes happening
as fast as possible,
we actually maintain empty MicroVM pools
on the hosts in various
different memory sizes.
When an invoke comes in,
the host management can then allocate
the smallest memory size
to satisfy the request
and then download the code or image.
And this then speeds up things a lot
as it can be a bit of time
to get an execution
environment up and running
and so we do them in advance.
For Firecracker workers,
Firecracker is the process
that sits above the OS
and then manages
the single secure execution
environment for invokes.
Within the execution environment
we maintain some of what we call sandboxes
and these are basically
privileged container name spaces,
one for your function code,
the runtime and extensions
or your container image.
And then we also maintain
a separate managed sandbox
which your code can't access
but allows us to manage
the things inside that
execution environment.
And an interesting thing
is we've actually completely rearchitected
how this works this year
to improve Lambda for how it works today
and also to build even
future functionality.
And it's been rolling out across our fleet
and you actually wouldn't know it
unless you knew where to look.
Trillions of invocations happening
and we're basically
swapping the tires of Lambda
while the car is moving at crazy speeds.
Outside of the sandboxes, we
also run a management agent
for control plane functionality
and also then a telemetry agent
which allows us to get metrics
and logs outta the execution
environment transparently.
The worker host then has a
bunch of other components,
host management coordinates
with other services,
builds and destroys those
execution environments.
The invoke proxy is the direct link
from Frontend to your code.
We also need to store MicroVM
files like runtime binaries
on the host for faster loading
and then we maintain a
cache for container images
and as many things as
we can for performance.
We also have agents that
then need to talk externally
to the container image chunk plane.
This is for downloading container images
and S3 for zip archives
to get your function code into
the execution environment.
And of course this needs
to connect elsewhere
and so there's networking to
connect to the outside world.
For Lambda Managed Instances,
it's actually pretty much the same,
although we are not using firecracker
but container D for the logical separation
and then containers instead
of actually MicroVM
execution environments.
So let's have a look onto async.
So it works in a similar
way to the sync service
but only handling async event requests.
And we've also recently
increased the payload
to one megabyte,
so you can now use it
for even more use cases.
The Frontend then sends the invoke request
to an internal SQS queue
and responds with an acknowledgement.
But they call it to say that Lambda
is going to invoke your
function asynchronously,
we got your request.
Lambda is gonna manage the SQS queues
and you don't actually even
have visibility of them.
We run a number of queues and
then dynamically scale 'em up
and down depending on the load
and the function concurrency.
Some of the queues are shared,
but we also have sent some
events to dedicated queues
to ensure that Lambda can handle
a huge amount of async invokes
with as little latency as possible.
We then have a fleet of poller
instances which we manage,
we're gonna cover that in more detail.
And these pollers read the messages
from the internal SQS queue
and then determine the function
accounts and the payload
and then ultimately it's gonna send
the invoke request synchronously,
again to the sync invoke service.
As you can see, all Lambda
invokes ultimately land up
as a sync invoke.
And the function uses
the same sync pathway
I talked about before,
returns a function response to the poller,
which then deletes the
message from the queue.
If the request is not successful,
the poller then doesn't actually delete
the message from the queue,
and uses the same visibility timeout
as you would with your own SQS queues.
And then the same or another poller
can pick up the message and try again.
You can also configure event
destinations for async invokes
to provide callbacks after the processing,
whether they invokes are successful
or they failed or after all
the retries are exhausted.
Some other control pain
services are involved.
There's the queue manager
which needs to look after the queues,
it's gonna monitor them
if they any backups
and does the creation and
deletion of the new queues.
And then it works and nicely
with the leasing service,
which then manages which pollers
are processing which queues.
And it can also detect when a poller fails
and so that their work can also
be passed to another poller.
So let's look at now
the event source mapping
or the poller invokes.
A producer application is
gonna then put messages
onto the stream or queue asynchronously.
We then run a number of
slightly different pollers
as we have different clients
depending on what the event source is.
And this is a very similar
architecture to async invokes.
From then on the pollers read the message
from the streamer queue,
can also filter them, batch them up
and then send them up to a single payload,
and sends your function synchronously
with the same sync Frontend service.
Remember all Lambda invokes
eventually land up being synchronous.
Then for queues,
the poller can then delete
the message from the queue
when your function
successfully processes them.
Depending on the event source,
you can then send information
again by the invoke
to SQS, SNS, EventBridge
S3, or even Kafka,
for Kafka sources, which
we announced recently.
There are also a number
of control plane services.
Again, state manager stream tracker,
depending on the event source,
manage the pollers,
manage the event sources,
discovers work, and then handle
scaling the poller fleets.
The leasing service is
going assign pollers
to work on a specific
event or streaming source.
If there's a problem, again,
it's gonna then move its
work to another poller.
And there are also
architectural differences,
but the two types of event sources,
queues and streams.
So queues is for
individual task processing
when each message is independent
and messages are deleted
after the processing.
And streams is then for when you're doing,
when you're multiple consumers
maybe need the same kind of data
and order particularly matters.
And then messages are gonna
be retried for replay,
two different architectural styles.
And the Lambda ESM, provides
a bunch of functionality
across all of these event sources.
We've got filtering, batch
controls, including for streams,
being able to split a batch
to find a faulty record.
We've got choosing where
to start in a stream,
retry and failure handling
analytics for Kinesis
and some platform performance
configuration options.
And the cool thing is
the Lambda ESM handles
this all for you.
You don't need to think about
the different characteristics
beyond just configuring your ESM.
We take on the task of making
everything actually happen.
So let's look a little deeper at the ESM
and see how it works with
both streaming and queuing.
The ESM pulls the event source,
the cure stream for available records.
Now, so we need to think
about even getting actually
to the event source.
SQS and Kinesis are on public endpoints,
but we also have events
sources that are connected
to private subnets or even
outside AWS often with Kafka.
So we need to handle that as well.
As well as the actual functions
which could be connected to a VPC.
Authentication depends
on the event source.
AWS ones we can use IAM,
but for Kafka we want to support
all the possible options,
authorization methods,
so the ESM can actually authenticate.
If there's ordering things like SQS FIFO
or streaming sources,
we always need to ensure that
the ordering is maintained
with the message processing.
For streams, you can configure
the starting position
as part of the ESM config,
from the beginning, from
a particular timestamped
or just getting from the latest records.
And the ESM also may needs to remember
where it was in the stream,
using the offset or sequence number.
We need to handle retries or resharding.
Streams can grow or shrink
and so we need to continually
look at the source
and see if there is maybe
a new Kafka broker online
or new shards or partitions to process
from one of the event sources.
The parent shard is split
creating a new child shard
and we need to maintain
ordering during this process
so we can send the right records
to new Lambda functions
to then scale up the processing.
For Kinesis,
there's a helpful additional setting
called tumbling windows,
which you can use for data aggregation.
You can pass the state
across multiple separate Lambda invokes
to aggregate data in real time.
Sort of quick and easy alternative way
for some analytic solutions.
There are also two ways
to consume from Kinesis.
You've got shared fan art
where you have to have up
to five consumers can share and
read throughput of a stream.
And then each shard supports
a read rate and a data rate,
and this has got a latency
of about 200 milliseconds.
But for faster responses to stream data,
you can actually set up Kinesis
enhanced fan-out or EFO.
This actually changes the flow
from the ESM pulling from Kinesis
to Kinesis sending to the ESM
using an HTTP push mechanism
to get to the data to the ESM faster
as low as 70 milliseconds.
So the ESM figures this out,
manages the change in logic flow
and this is just handled transparently,
something you don't have
to look after yourself.
There's also dedicated
poller offering for SQS
and recent for Kafka
and recently actually SQS
where we can also provision
of pollers in advance to
be able to handle spikes.
You can configure various settings,
mainly the minimum and maximum pollers
to be able to control the throughput,
and this can dramatically
increase your polling, scaling
and throughput.
16 times for SQS up to
20,000 concurrency compared
to the standard polling of 1250 for SQS.
Kafka also simplifies the networking
and the cost models when you enable this.
And there is an additional
charge to be able to do this
and it's based on an event processing unit
which you can manage.
And so provision mode is
great for high traffic sources
where you want low latency
and also this can save you some
polling money at big scale.
And provision mode allows us to build
and bring new functionality
to the pollers,
like supporting schema registries
and allowing efficient binary formats
like Avro and Protobuf.
Okay, so we have done the polling,
then the filtering allows
you to dump records,
you don't want to process, why?
Well, filtering is a CPU intensive process
and you don't really want to do that
and waste Lambda invokes
in your code.
So you can have positive
filtering to include messages
that you do wanna include
or negative to exclude or messages
that don't match a
particular specific criteria.
This is very flexible
using the same syntax
as EventBridge filtering.
And here in this example
we are processing messages
for the tire pressure less than 32
to send that only those to your function.
Next up is batching.
For batching actually the records
for grouping the records
for efficient processing,
and this means you can control
your Lambda invokes for efficiency.
So how are batches defined?
Well you get to configure this
and control this in a
number of three ways.
You can configure the size
and this is one up to a default of 10,000.
We normally start at 10, the
number of items in the batch,
but yeah up to 10,000 that is really big.
And then the batch window is
to help improve efficiency
when you don't actually have much traffic.
So you can at least process messages
before whole batch is formed.
And you need to also stay
within the Lambda six meg payload limit.
So once there is a batch,
we then need to invoke the function
via the sync control plane.
So we need to then
consider different scaling
for the different architectures.
Streaming isn't actually
an upper bound problem.
You wanna process data
with a stream generally
as fast as possible.
And so there's a maximum
throughput you want to factor in.
So with Kinesis and Kafka
streams you're trying to consume
and process messages at
the highest rate possible
to keep up with the incoming data,
and to minimize the lag.
And the challenge is
in scaling up to exceed
or meet at least or possibly
exceed the ingestion rate.
But queuing is different.
This is actually a lower bound problem.
You do want to process data efficiently,
but you also want to ensure
you're not actually
overwhelming downstream services
like you know APIs or databases.
So with SQS the queue is
actually acting as a buffer
or a shock absorber and you
are then controlling the rate
where you wanna drain the queue
to then protect those
downstream resources.
And the challenge is then maintaining
a minimum safe processing rate,
that is gonna respect
those downstream resources.
So two different architectural styles.
And so for SQS to do this,
we want to manage the flow control,
the rate at which Lambda
consumes the messages.
And so you can configure the
max concurrency on the ESM
to control how many concurrent executions
the ESM is then gonna
attempt to send to Lambda,
to prevent overwhelming
downstream services.
And this is actually
the all important buffering control.
Reserve concurrency is
in a separate setting
on the Lambda function,
which you set to reserve
capacity from the function.
And this ensures it can
scale up with needed
within the available account concurrency.
So you actually rather wanna
use the max concurrency
to manage the buffer and the flow,
but you can also use both together.
And if you do, you wanna make sure
that the reserve concurrency
is higher than the maximum concurrency
to prevent any throttling.
So for also streams we need to scale up
how the stream scales.
This is automatically
the ESM just needs to figure this out.
Kinesis scales by adding shards
and Kafka by adding partitions
and Lambda is automatically
gonna figure this all out
and is gonna scale up the consumer pollers
to match their incoming throughput.
Still with message ordering
in each partition or shard,
more shards or partitions
means more processing.
But customers wanted even
more processing for Kinesis.
So we came up with what's
called parallelization factor.
By default it's one function
per individual shard,
but you can scale up to 10
for massive Lambda throughput,
still maintaining the order.
And this is something spills
built specifically for Lambda,
for high throughput stream processing.
For error handling, streams and queues
also have different semantics.
Streams need to produce
or preserve the ordering,
but you actually need
to figure out and decide
what to do with the poison pill message.
Should that actually stop processing?
If it's something like log data
or bank transactions, you know,
absolutely you wanna
stop the steam processing
and you wanna fix the problem
before continuing processing,
but maybe force, you know,
some frequent sensor data
or I don't know, you know
GPS data from a higher car
you can handle some of that data loss
'cause you know, in a few seconds time
the next result's gonna come in
and you can still continue shortly.
So in this scenario,
you don't actually want to stop
the stream because you want
to keep the message processing going.
And then for queues,
generally you don't wanna stop
for a failed message
and you wanna continue
to process the rest.
And
we then have two batch
error handling things
to give you some more control.
Partial batch response
is when you know the failed record
and you're a container
of successful response
and then tell the ESM
which message has failed
and then that's gonna go to be retried
and processing continue.
And AWS power tools for a
WS Lambda is a great utility
for using for lots of languages
and that's got a batch processing
utility to help with this.
And for streams, bisecting
batches can be super useful
when you don't handle the error
and it's not something you normally need
to consider for queues.
So in this example,
message three is a bad one,
although we wouldn't actually know it yet.
And so we process the batch
and get a failed response.
Instead of end endlessly
retrying the same batch.
The ESM can then split the
batch, try the first half
to keep ordering and try to
get more messages processed.
The split batch fails again
as it has the faulty message.
And so the ESM splits again and we now try
and process the new batches.
This time the first batch
processes successfully
and the single batch for the
poison message fails again.
And we can then continue
with the original second half
of the first batch to
keep up that ordering
of the successful messages.
And then can fully
process as many messages
as possible without having
to reject a whole batch
and then deal with a faulty
message if we want to,
really efficient way that you can control.
And then we need to
handle function errors.
So we need to configure
Lambda on failure destinations
for the function in vogue issues.
And then you might think,
well why are there actually
two different error
handing parts for SQS?
Well the SQS deal queue
is gonna capture messages
that fail repeatedly during the polling
or the processing,
while the on failure destinations
is gonna capture invoke errors
with your Lambda function.
And this could be things like
network issues or throttling
or maybe you've deleted the function
or there's a function permission issue.
And so both serve different processes
and can be used together for
comprehensive error handling.
And so that takes us through
the Lambda fundamentals.
We've covered sync,
async, workers, pollers,
and all the features of
the event source mapping.
Again, it just looks like
a configuration option,
but Lambda underneath
the hood is doing a huge amount of work,
doing some pulling, doing some pushing,
doing some pulling, you know,
being as efficient as possible
to be able to get the messages
from the different
architectures of your streams
and your queues.
So let me now hand back over to Rajesh
who's gonna dive deeper into the pollers
and talk about some of the lessons
we learned about when
we were building Lambda.
- Okay.
(audience clapping)
- Hello.
- Thanks Julian.
(Rajesh coughing)
Yeah, the cold start.
Yeah, Lambda that cold
start, you know, yeah.
Hi.
Hello everyone again, this is Rajesh.
Today I'll be talking about,
let me give you the overview
of like I have divided
this segment of the talk into two parts.
One is like I'll walk you
through the mental model
of like some of the mental models
that we have used while designing Lambda
and the operational complexity
in that comes with it.
And how that complexity actually
fueled a lot of innovation
that we have baked into Lambda design.
So let's start with
the mental model first.
Last time we stood here
and convinced you that
like Lambda in some ways
is a storage service,
and applies a lot of learnings
from building services
like EBS formulation service like EBS.
And this year I want to convince you
that Lambda is also a queuing service
and like how we have applied a lot
of learnings from
building queuing services
and a queuing theory concepts.
I know compute as a queuing service
seems a bit counterintuitive,
but let me explain what
I actually mean by that.
And I'll walk you through
like the thought process
of designing this Lambda service.
So what's the queue service?
Let's start with that.
I started with Amazon back in 2013,
so it's been more than a decade.
And the first thing that I did
was build a queue processor
and basically a key processor
is there's a message buffer
where a lot of events
and messages are stored
and there is a worker
which actually pulls.
So you write a way to deal with the queue
and then you have a business
logic that you process
your messages and do something with it.
And for that I had to
build a lot of simulations
and during I had to build
a lot of simulations
to like go through model my
upstreams model, my downstreams,
what are the failure points
and like what would it take
to build a resilient service.
Back then Lambda didn't existed,
so I had to do a lot
of like heavy lifting,
and I had to build the key
processor from scratch on my own.
And when I joined Lambda
that is 2018, '19 time,
I realized that the same
pattern shows up everywhere.
Many of the features that we built
and many of the things Julian
just walked you through
are inspired by that same analysis.
I've been doing this since 2013
as I told you over a decade.
So let me quickly walk you
through the queuing theory.
So that will set the foundation
for the next of the rest of the session.
Queuing theory is nothing fancy
but just basically study
of the waiting lines,
how things arrive and
wait and get processed
and leave.
This diagram is basic.
There's a basic shape
of every queuing system,
you have probably you see,
probably you have seen some version of it,
events arrive at some rate and
that rate is never defined.
Like some customers go crazy,
they spike, some are like slow
and has bounded key arrival pattern.
On the right side, what
you see is a worker,
their speed is the service
rate just like arrivals,
this isn't constant like
sometimes your data,
your dependency can take more than
if it is taking like 10 milliseconds.
Sometimes it can take like milliseconds.
So like this is also not like well done.
So you have to model
different things around it.
And next what you see here
is like the buffer bust
and variability.
The variance is when you,
you are building a queuing
service there, there comes a lot
of like variance in terms
of if there's a spike
or if there's a threat issue
or if your services are not,
not able to like hand up, like
deal with the process,
deal with the workload,
then it may run into some issues.
And that vari is a simple one,
variance into the system can lead
to build up of the backlog.
So I'll talk more about it
when we go into like specific
sections of this.
So let's, let's look at the lessons
that Lambda has learned
from the Queuing theory
and like how it applied it.
The first things I want to
talk about is the lesson
that we learned from Queuing Theory
is like buffers is smooth variance,
arrivals are never uniform.
They are busty, they spike,
they're unpredictable,
and so we don't try to
handle them right away.
That's impossible and expensive.
You can always provision for,
like the peak,
but then you would end up
like paying a lot more for it.
The second lesson
is like we specialized
workers for workload types.
And I'll talk about like
how this led to design
of like how Lambda,
in terms of like how we separated pollers
from like the Lambda execution environment
and why the nature of different poller,
the poller workers different,
than the execution environment.
And the third is the control variance
to prevent instability.
Even if an average arrival rate
is less than average service rate,
variance can cause temporary,
very instability and that
variance skill system.
And the fourth is like
coordinate shared resources
through centralized control.
In Queuing theory models,
the work conservation
means if there's a work
and if there's a server.
So work servers should
never sit idle basically,
but theory assumes there is
always exist a global state.
In distributed system,
you have to build it.
And I'll talk about like
how Lambda has to build it.
So let's first start with like
this buffers smooth variance
as I was talking about,
like the topic pattern
is always variable.
There are customers with
the steady state traffic,
there are customers with random traffic,
some customers spike, extremely
spike like they are...
They can spike from like 10 x to like 50 x
and you have to have a system
which actually takes care of this thing.
There are some customers,
those who are like slowly ramping up
and suddenly they become
the real customers.
And, some of the customers
can bust like can have
micro busty patterns.
That you have to have a system
which can actually handle this.
And like,
so what you're basically
building is a ingestion tier
where there are data sources,
there's an ingestion tier
and there's a storage leverage,
where the system,
the traits of that system
is that it can accept highly
variable multi-tenant traffic.
After you've taken the traffic,
you need to normalize
and validate the request
and you have to write the message
or events to the right queue.
You have to persist it and acknowledge it.
Before acknowledging you need to make sure
that like it's persisted durably.
And then you also have to
apply admission control
and back pressure to protect yourself.
So if you have to build
something of this sort,
you would need to...
Like you need to have
a durable architecture
which actually helps you build
this like ingestion tier.
So what Lambda did,
this is like the layer of the customers,
they variable customers.
What we do, we have a load
balancer where like you,
whenever the first time that you invoke,
so like Julian was talking
about like Frontend
and invoke, event invoke Frontend.
So this is the Frontend
that is the event invoke Frontend,
and it has a bunch of things
like the distributed load
like health checks and all.
And once you have that, like
it hits the upper Frontend
like this is called like reverse proxy,
you can call it that,
which is like multi AZ service
and has like bunch of like host on it.
And at the same time it's also
has a like autoscaling rules
so that like if there is
a spike in heat in CPU
or memory or something,
a bunch of these things,
then it can autoscale on its own.
Apart from that, we also have to build,
like once you have gotten
the ingestion tier done,
like you also have to passage the message
as I was talking about.
So you have to have a buffer
and this buffer needs to be durable
in the sense that like
you can't lose message
once you have told it to your customers
that like we have accepted a message,
but also what at the end of the day,
the thing that you want
to do is like it should go
into the queue where you can process it.
We don't want to just invest the message,
but we also want to process it.
So how do we build that like
routing layer in between?
Let me walk you through that.
So first thing is like
there's an invoke request
that comes in with the event message,
then it goes through
a chain of validators,
you do authentication,
then you do validate the payload,
then you look at the function
whether there's active function or not.
And then once you pass
this validation layer,
you need to find the queue
where the message can be ingested.
And again, like I was talking about,
we have millions of customers,
we can't have like millions of queues.
So there has to be like some sort of like,
a multi-tenancy within the queues.
So for that, the most popular pattern
I think you guys might
have seen is like building
a set of queues and then hashing
them onto like a hash ring
and then doing that
multi-tenancy for the customers.
So what we do when massive message passes
through all the validation share,
we find the queue finder,
we hash it onto like the
partition of the hash ring
and once we have found the partition,
we take that message,
we have gotten the queue
and then we write it to that
queue, whatever that queue
that we found on the hash ring.
But this is as you know,
like even the single partition,
can get like really, really hot
because now millions of customers,
a lot of them can overlap
onto like the same partition.
So what we do is,
we went back and then we use
a technique called shuffle sharding,
where shuffle sharding is nothing.
Basically it's like,
instead of liking hashing a customer
onto like a single queue,
now you can hash that customers
onto like multiple queues.
So what we do is we hash a single customer
based on the account already
and there are like some
heuristics that we have.
We hash that customer to
like now two hash ranges.
We pick the queues based
on those hash ranges
and then find the queue
which has the lowest
queue depth at that time,
and then inserts the message in there.
So this is what we do,
this is what we call like shuffle sharding
and it does wonders for us
and it helps us remove like
this like hot partitioning
and it goes away.
In addition to this,
we also have something
called like express lane.
So once we know like,
okay, we know this customer
is going to be noisy and it'll
be having a lot more traffic,
we already create like a
sideline queue for them.
We let them like absorb
and we absorb their traffic
and then once they're done
we can reap their queue
and back them into like
those dynamic shared queues.
And this was what I talked
about so far is like the queues
that are managed by Lambda,
those are like event invoke queues.
So whenever you ingest Lambda,
invoke Lambda in like
asynchronous manners,
that is where it goes.
That's another part of the buffer
which is like helping us like smoothen
the variance is like customer owned.
So this is like the event
source mapping side of things
where like the queues and the streams
and everything, it stays
on the customer boundaries.
All we do is like we have the processing,
and from this point onwards,
the polling becomes same
for both of, both.
Like the, either it is customer-managed
or it is service-managed.
So let's, the second
lesson that we applied
that specialized workers
for workload types.
Let's look at how Lambda work
Lambda applies this lesson.
Number two, to understand it,
let's further understand what a worker is.
It's not typical worker,
but a worker is nothing
but a processor which looks at the queue
and whenever it sees a message
or an event, it processes it.
What queuing theory showed us
that heterogeneous server service
with different service rates
need to be dealt differently
for best performance.
We applied this
and we separated the polling workloads
from execution workloads.
Both polling and execution workloads
are different in nature.
Polling is continuous
stateful connection heavy.
On the other hand execution is busty,
stateless and short-lived.
So what you see here
is there are actually two types of worker.
One is a polling worker
that is managed by Lambda
and there is a Lambda function
that like customers write.
Julian talked about
this side of the worker
and like the Lambda
worker execution round.
I want to dive David today
onto like the poller side poller worker.
So let's jump right in.
So what are the key
components that make a poller?
I divided and I looked into
like our, like what we do today.
So this, this changes all the time.
We learn new things and we evolve.
So this is what we have today.
What we have like a work
acquire this component looks
at like if there's a active work,
so it looks into like an
assignment manager store.
It says that okay there's an SQS cube
or there's a stream, there's
a work that is there.
So what it does, it picks up the work
and it starts the event
source configuration.
So like for in the case of a
stream, like for KCL Kinesis,
it's KCL for Kafka, it's Kafka consumer
for SQS client.
What it does, like once it's configured,
it kick starts this work, it
con configures the connector
and pulls the record
and then writes it into
like an memory queue buffer.
So a lot of features that
Julian was talked about
are being done in this
like in-memory queue
where we create this view
so we don't kind of
pressure the event source
and we build this view.
And this is where like you
do batching your filtering,
your schema industry validation.
If it supports that.
Then we have this like an
invoke orchestrator layer
where once you have your batch is ready,
then batching can be for different ways.
Batching, Julian talked about like three
of the ways we do the batching.
Once you have the batch ready
with your conditions defined,
you do the invoke orchestrator.
What it does it like invokes your Lambda
in synchronous manner with a batch
and it deals with the record.
If it is failing, then
it it, it hands it off
to like the error handling
component which rides to DLQ
or retries, whatever
is it appropriate based
on your configuration.
In addition to this, like if
your message is successful,
we have a check pointer
manager which actually deals
with like an advancing checkpoint.
So that like this says that okay,
before deleting a message, we make sure
that like your system is, has processed it
and we are not losing any message.
In addition to this, this
is an auto-scaler we have.
So it looks at the current
state of the system
and says that, okay, whether I need
to auto scale if I'm
running hot, I should look
into the signals of my worker right now
and say that okay, I
need to scale further.
And scaling can be in, in two parts.
One is like vertically scaling.
If I have a capacity in my host,
so I look at the footprint
of my memory and CPU
and say that okay, I can vertically scale
to absorb some more traffic.
Or if I cannot,
then I will signal it to like
some of my global coordinator
to say that okay, I need more help.
So can you like spin up new workers for me
and then like take on the that work?
Apart from that, if I'm running hot,
I also want to load-shed
some of the workers.
So like we have a load-shedding component
which actually removes the
work if I'm running hot.
I don't want to impact my customers.
In addition to that,
there's like an overall
like health checker
which keeps looking into like
different parts of the system
and making that data available
to different components.
So Auto-scaler looks into
that data and says that,
okay, oh, I think I have, I'm running hot,
I need to auto-scale.
And load-shed said,
okay, I'm running hot, I
need to load-shed something.
In memory cube first also,
like similarly like it builds that view
and then makes it available
to like reprint components.
So what we did so far is like workers
and the view of that worker
and like what it takes
to build that worker.
But not every worker is same.
Some workers are more secure.
Some need to like go
through the BPC boundaries.
So what we did is like we
went back to the drawing board
and looked hard at it
that what is the an
anatomy of the pollers,
and what can we done there?
So if you, this is what we
just saw, and we squinted,
like literally we squinted,
and saw that like, okay,
if we slice the worker horizontally,
we basically get the bottom up apart
where all the system touch points are.
We squinted even harder.
And I'm talking literally,
I squinted a little harder.
A bottom half can be further divided
into three parts with three
different touch points.
And let me share what I meant
by that if you look closely,
the one part of that worker
is actually dealing with event sources,
and one part of the
worker is actually dealing
with the internal service communication,
doing the internal service communication.
And another part is dealing
with like the Lambda private invocations,
and all three have different
security boundaries
that you are operating with.
So what we did is we said,
okay, let's pick this part of the worker
and wrap it into like one
specific set of security boundary,
then pick this set up the worker
and put it into one
specific security boundary.
And the last part was like
Lambda execution environment,
which like you can have a
very private VPC function
that we can invoke.
And what else?
Like we applied the same principle
that we applied to Lambda worker
and Lambda pollers.
We applied the same principle
within the Lambda poller
workers and said that okay,
even there, there are three parts.
So now we can automatically
scale a part of that worker,
which is independent and has nothing to do
with the rest of the worker.
So think about like if you
have worked with Kafka,
then you know the problem
around consumers rebalancing.
There's like death loop,
and then like a bunch of
things that have been done,
like the static stability,
static membership and then
cooperative rebalance.
What if we can separate these two things
in such a way that like you can deal
with the consumers separately
then actually increasing throughput
by invoking Lambda functions?
So we did that, we wrapped
them into security boundary,
where like one is like dealing
with the customer resource,
one is dealing with the internal services
and one is dealing with
the function execution.
So we can have a VPC peering
between execution environment
and the poller workers.
We can have a cross-account connectivity
with the customer event source
and the internal service,
where like this is within
the same boundaries
where it is operating.
Now that we understand poller workers,
let's look at the next lesson
that we got from the queuing theory,
which tells us about
the production behavior
of these workers.
Let's look at that.
The lesson number three
is the control variance
to prevent instability.
And as I said like
variance skills systems.
So let's take a deeper look at it.
What you see here is a workload
which has a high latency
once it has gone through
and like now it started to
absorb a lot more resources
of the system,
and that leaves like the workload B
and workload C with no
resources to work with.
And as Little's Law dictates
that if processing latency increases,
concurrency will spike even
with a constant arrival rate.
Now, at this point,
we want to build some sort of
like a fairness in our system.
So what do we do?
To deal with, we built multiple
layers of defense control,
different layers of like mechanisms
to maintain the stability into the system.
The first one is like variance reduction.
The first layer
is, if you're getting
messages into the queue,
try to batch them, for example.
The second one is like
the capacity controls,
set hard limits, like
capping the concurrency,
so a single function
can't overrun the fleet.
Third is control what comes in.
Throttle requires when you
are full, just like a store,
locking the door at the
capacity, for example,
and back pressure, react when overloaded.
You don't have to suffer.
Slowdown polling or shared low priority.
These are like four
layers that we have built.
Again, these are layers that we have built
and some of these layer can
be configured by the customers
and some of these are like owned
by and managed by service team.
Now that we have arrived,
looked at the arrival pattern,
workers and what keep
the service running load,
one more thing that I talked about
is coordinate shared resources
through centralized component.
What queuing theory says that okay,
there is always a determination
or stable pattern.
Whenever one worker dies,
the other worker picks it up.
We don't have that luxury
in a distributor system.
So like we have to build
this global state on our own.
What it takes to build that global state.
So global state has four traits in it.
One is work conserving scheduling,
is like if there is a work
and there's an idle worker,
we should try to pair them up.
Conflict-free assignment.
If one worker is working on it,
don't give it to someone else
so that they're not like
thrashing each other.
The capability of a dispatch,
like you know, you are
giving work to someone
and it can handle that specific work.
Like I don't want to give like
a queuing worker an SQS work
to an stream poller, for example.
And the failure detection and recovery.
If someone has claimed the work
and it is actually not working on it,
then I should have a
way to know that someone
is not actually actively progressing that.
So what do we do?
We have a control plane.
Basically, like whenever you create an ESM
or you could create an
event in work config,
it goes to a config store.
And then we have an ESM lifecycle manager,
whose job is to bring worker
and make it available to the system
so that it can work on it, act on it.
Then we create an assignment.
With that assignment,
there's another separate service
called Assignment Manager,
where it stores the assignment
details into the config.
And this is where like we
build that global state.
And as I talked about
like the poller worker,
it gets the work,
then it heartbeats and
sends the master data back
to the assignment config store,
which is the source of like
we having the global state.
And at the same time,
like this is like an end-to-end drop job,
which is making sure that everything,
whoever is claiming the work,
they have the work and
they're acting on it.
And if they're not acting on it,
then I want to involve the human operators
so that it can take an action on it.
And this leads to what you
saw, what Julian showed you,
the Lambda poller worker
architecture looks like.
And you have seen it like multiple times
and this was the under-the-hood part
of building this kind of architecture.
Let's quickly recap.
Ingestion tier and buffer,
you need to have a
buffer-smoothening mechanism.
There are worker, and
there are different types.
Some has a different traits.
So you should like try
to separate them out.
The stability controls
variance skill your system.
So you need to have like
controls so that you can maintain
and build stability to your system.
And the global state
that is needed for you to like
make the continuous progress.
And this is what we needed,
need to keep fleet healthy.
And this basically tells you
almost everything that you need
to know about how Lambda applies lessons
from queuing theory,
and hope I, by now,
I give you some idea on
like why I said like Lambda
is also a queue service in many ways.
And Lambda has millions of customers
and millions of events flowing
through these systems.
So how do we keep everything running?
Seeing everything upfront
is really, really hard
and as a wise person said,
it's like Everything fails all the time.
So once you have the
queue, you have the worker.
What do you do if it fails?
So this second part of
the talk I talked about
is like how do we deal
with operational complexity
on operating a queue service like this?
Obviously, we had to innovate
on different dimensions
to run it quickly.
In queuing theory, it tells us
that failures are independent,
systems scales linearly
and saturations happen gradually.
It's the kind of world you would
like to see as an engineer.
But the moment you operate
a real multi-tenant distributed system,
you realize that everything gets messier.
The reality is there
are correlated failures.
If one service fails, you see
like, oh, other service starts to fail.
System don't scale linearly.
If there's a retry loop
happening somewhere,
then they accelerate faster,
and the cliff drop.
It's like you model
something in your simulation,
you always miss out that one condition
which leads to like some
sort of like a cliff drop.
And when I say cliff, I mean this cliff.
If you remember, back in 2013,
Lambda had an outage where a latent bug
in our Frontend free surfaced
and that led to increasing error rate.
This is the case I'm talking about.
It's really, really hard to model
all the cases while you are testing.
Same in the case with the queue service.
You can't model everything,
but what you can do
is like build a system
which can recover from this.
While there are many things we do,
I've captured three
main resiliency pattern
that we apply to operate Lambda.
The first one is like
a dependency outages.
What do we do when the codependency
that we rely on to build the
skiing service goes away?
The scale in version, what
if like a bigger fleet,
it starts to hammer the smaller fleet?
What do we do?
And the third is like
availability zone outage.
It's very special and very
unique to like the problem
how we solve it and
like how it is different
for like operating a queuing service.
So let's start with the dependency outage.
Let's look at the recent
outage October 2025.
I think it's pretty fresh
in everyone's memory.
This was the recent DDB outage
with a bunch of service got impacted.
Lambda was one of them.
We used DDB for various things
to operate our data play.
The root cause of this issue
was a latent race condition
in DynamoDB DNS management.
I think there is a talk
you guys should attend
if you're interested
in what happened here.
Now if you think from the point of view
of queue service operator,
this becomes even more interesting.
What you see here is that
when an outage happens,
we start to accumulate messages.
Now when the dependency is recovered,
we have to deal with backlog
that we have accumulated
with a new traffic, which is coming.
And to catch up,
we have to now start like we have
to work twice as hard, right?
We have accumulated some messages
and the new set of messages
are still coming in.
So what do we do?
The second kind of thing
that we see is like a fairness conundrum
of what I call it is like a noisy customer
is a noisy customer,
but a good customer becomes noisy customer
because now there is no way for us
to like that noisy customer has 100,000
of messages or millions of messages.
A good customer, a good
citizen also has like millions
of messages now because we were out.
So we started to accumulate,
like how do we differentiate between that?
And so what do we do?
Like whenever there is an outage,
we want to clear the
backlog as soon as possible,
but we also don't want to
hammer our service down
so that like we delay the recovery.
It's a balancing act.
It always turns into balancing act for us
whenever there's an outage.
If we are under-flowing, then
we are delay your recovery.
So your message is
staying in queue longer,
but if we are overflowing, then
we may tip over the service,
which is actually because
there is a capacity
that we are provision and
there is like a finite amount
of work that you could do.
You can like have buffer
and you can unlock a lot of capacity,
but still there is the amount of work log
that you have accumulated
can take more time.
There are a few things that we do,
and I'll talk about like
some of those strategies,
and this is not exhaustive by any means,
but there are a few things
which are interesting.
I wanted to share that.
One thing that we build
is, we build a gradual
ramp using a token bucket.
That token bucket rate
is controlled through
the view of the systems,
like how our CPU and
memory pressure is looking.
How is our sync traffic looking?
How is our different modes
of invocations are looking?
And then we build that
and tune the rate of our
TPS that we are generating
through this like asynchronous fleet
to gradually recover so that
we are not tipping over,
and then we have this handshake mechanism.
Every time there is an outage,
we build this automated
handshake mechanism
where we keep looking into
like dialing up the knob
and then looking at the rate
at which like how our
service is recovering?
We also look at try to
convert a FIFO queue
into a LIFO queue wherever...
Like if you have a backlog
and you are okay to go ahead
and then start looking
into the first messages.
So we start to try to create
and shed the customer.
So like old message, the
backlog can drain slowly,
but your new messages,
so that's why you see recovery very fast.
We also sometimes if you have a function,
you have a version.
So we try to shard your
cues into like a function
and a function version and
then an alias so that you start
to see recovery much faster.
And then as I was saying,
good customer can become noisy
and noisy customers is a noisy customer.
So like how do we isolate these things?
So for that, like think
about like a customer
has like millions of messages
and set their function concurrency to one.
So how do we deal with that?
Like now that customer is in the queue,
we try to isolate that
customers from the own queue
so it can have its own processing,
because it's not a noisy customer,
it's the outage that made it noisy.
So we have another kind of
like a token-bucket mechanism
where we assign a set buffers
or like give tokens based
on whatever the function concurrency,
downstream configurations are.
And we assign that one
single specific token bucket
to that customer and then
like try to isolate them,
so that like they have,
even if they're in the CIQ,
they are now using that token bucket
to say that this is their
processing capacity.
So this was about like what
happens when dependency is out?
There's another kind of outage
that we have to deal with
is like a scale inversion,
whereas a big fleet is
depending on a small fleet
and in small plate goes out
or big fleet behave weirdly,
which led to a small fleet going out.
So this is another outage
where like a large surge
of connection led to a...
And a retry storm happened,
which led to a small fleet going out.
And then also at the same
time like the control plane
was like recovering which
would delayed the recovery.
And for us it becomes, if you
think about like that work,
the global state view, like
the leasing services out,
if this is out for like one minute,
we have accumulated messages
and we have keep continuing
to getting like new messages.
So how do we recover from that?
And it becomes that problem for us.
And so for that, like we
build static stability.
What I mean by static stability
is the ability of a workload to continue
to correct continue operation
despite dependency impairment,
without requiring reactive changes.
The most critical step to
achieving the static stability
is separating the hot
path from the cold path.
Data plan doesn't need
to call control plane
during the processing.
Control plane only needs to
like do the lifecycle management
and data plan is sufficient to
operate in the steady state.
One of the strategies is like
we push down the configuration
for a Lambda case.
We push the Lambda
function configuration down
to the pollers instead of like
poller asking for that work.
The second is like replicating the state,
like L1 and L2, I think Julian
talked briefly about it.
We also use disk as a backup
so that like we can consume the work
and like restart the work,
resume the work where it is,
if there's an outage.
And then build is stickiness
with a flexible time out.
So we try to reduce the false positive
from like the false negatives.
If there's an outage
and we say like it's
a (indistinct) outage,
don't leave your work,
don't release your work.
Lease-driven independence means partitions
has their own dedicated worker
or shared dedicated workers.
And the circuit breaker is
like if you see like the error
is spread across the whole fleet,
that means maybe there is nothing common
with like that one specific host,
but it is spread across
the whole of the system.
And the third kind of outage
is like availability outage.
What I mean with that,
like availability outage is very weird.
There can be like a thunderstorm somewhere
and that led down to outage
of like an availability zone.
So what happens for us if there is an AZ,
there are three AZ sample workload.
If there's one AZ out,
we have to migrate because
we have millions of queues
that we are processing and
there are millions of workers
and that relationship.
So like we have to migrate
that work active workload
from that AZ to another AZ,
and that migration requires
some effort in on our site.
So what do we do?
Like we have AZ buffer.
This is very standard
like if you have capital
processing capacity
and you need to move the work,
you need to have the buffer
so that you can take on the work.
The second, and again,
this is like another balancing act for us
where like if you are one AZ is impacted,
you need to move the work
to like the other AZ,
but you don't want to
impact the other AZ also
with that outage.
So we have like hardware-based mechanism
where like we are reactively
like we let the leases expire,
and then that becomes
available and then gets shared.
But it takes longer time.
And what if like Lambda has
recovered other workers?
We have moved the workers
from like unhealthy AZ
to like healthy AZ,
now we need time to,
and if we are taking time to migrate,
then there is no point in
like having that recovery.
So we need to do, get
more proactive in that.
We have divided that
into like three parts,
like detection, we need to first make sure
that like there is an AZ outage,
we are very confident about it.
Then we evacuate, and then we
observe, continuously observe
that like there is an outage,
there is a, like the work
has migrated to that new AZ
and then like if when
the recovery happened
we need to move it back.
So the key takeaways
are, architectural key takeaways
designed for busty, unpredictable,
reduce processing variability, isolate.
And operational key takeaways
around, multi-tenancy is the default,
failures are constant,
and stability comes before scale.
And with that I'll hand it over to Julian.
Thank you.
- Excellent.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
We've only got a little bit of time left,
but I just wanted to quickly go
through some of the things with Lambda.
We talked about Lambda Managed Instances,
all the flexibility of Lambda
with EC2 control plane as well.
Lambda durable functions a whole way.
Messes up all the way you're
thinking about Lambda,
built for asynchronous processing,
but all within a single Lambda function.
Build long for running workflows
in your favorite programming languages.
Another session is happening
on that this afternoon.
Tenant isolation,
providing execution
isolation between tenants.
You just give a tenant ID.
This is great for SaaS customers
who have maybe hundreds
of thousands of functions,
makes it much better for them.
Event source mapping enhancements.
We've got schema registry
which has been released.
The provision mode for SQS I mentioned,
and also a whole bunch of
ESM metrics were available
to help you building your applications.
And the future, well, of course,
there's plenty more to do.
We'll always be helping
with observability,
bringing new updates, new
runtimes as quickly as we can,
working hard on price to
make Lambda applicable
for all workloads.
More deeper integrations with
AWS and third-party services.
And always we continue to
listen to your feedback.
Let us know what you
would like us to make.
Make to build our Lambda
roadmap is now public available
on GitHub, so you can help us
to find the future of Lambda.
Lots of other kind of
sessions, manage instances,
durable functions, the future
of serverless tomorrow.
And I did a talk on best
practices yesterday.
Hopefully that'll be on YouTube
and useful for you as well.
Another slide here just
on a bunch of whole,
a lot of serverless kind of things
to continue your serverless learning.
But most importantly,
thank you so much today for coming,
early in the morning.
I appreciate you taking the time
to learn a little bit more about Lambda.
Hopefully, you can understand
there's a huge amount
that happens under the hood,
so you can just consume Lambda
as a great service without having to worry
about all the flow control,
all the other kind of things that Rajesh
and his team is building.
So thank you very much
for joining us today,
and enjoy the rest of your Reinvent.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)